a man who is uh not only in all-time
Steeler great but also part of on
location experiences of the National
Football League which we will be
discussing but also a longtime friend of
this program back to the Rich Eisen
podcast days as Brockman we talked about
earlier in the show you were the on
field producer segment producer well not
on field on carpet producer that's right
Academy Awards back in the day of this
man correct correct
over five years ago my gosh time flies
Hines Ward back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you hon do you know but we
have most importantly forget about
football history television we have
Oscar history Hines I do recall Clooney
came up to you on the carpet right did
he you know he's a former Baltimore
Ravens cheerleaders but he respected you
that's the point right
I'm sure you heard after that Monday
night Donnybrook with the Cincinnati
Bengals Hines Ben Roethlisberger when
asked about why the tenor of the game
was the way it was and he just said AFC
North football and that was the end of
that so which which do you think is more
representative of AFC North football the
the Bengal Steelers game or the Ravens
Steelers game that we saw a week later
and still it's just because of what's at
stake I mean we always know you know
when I have seen or they do they're
gonna go to Baltimore Pittsburgh
Cincinnati of late you know they've been
playing good ball but just you know that
rivalry kind of would never really
arrived it was like a spark plug but it
hasn't been consistent here in the year
out and I think for Baltimore distillers
I mean you always going to get a great
game regardless of whatever teams their
records are you know is always going to
come down to go
series whoever had the ball laughs it's
gonna win that game Hines Ward here with
me on the Rich Eisen show do you think
Antonio Brown is an MVP candidate I
think he's one candidate but Antonio we
can't do it with by himself I mean I've
said you have to have Ben Roethlisberger
in the state charter court these guys on
the ball and he's been playing
outstanding in the month of December I
mean by over 500 yards passing and at
the same time you know yes Antonio's
great catching the ball well I think
Ben's thrown some nice passes to Antonio
man and just like you know the two go
hand in hand a very unstoppable and you
know you put them together and the
reporter they have is just amazing I've
never seen anything like it
you know having the trust and and the
rapport with the wire receiver and
knowing what he's going to do at all
times and they're giving him the
opportunity so yes babies having an MVP
season but I think a lot of that has to
do with their rosters world was it you
know if you lose Ben Roethlisberger
I think the dynamics but that totally
safe I agree with you Hines and I said
it the other day that I don't know why
but okay obviously you were the MVP of
that Super Bowl Big Ben Big Ben was just
a young quarterback at the time and he
did have his struggles in that game the
second Super Bowl that you guys won
together
somebody had to deliver Santonio Holmes
those footballs throughout the entirety
of the second half of that game and
certainly that last Drive in Tampa yeah
it just seems to me over and over again
and certainly a quarterback of an 11 win
team would be at the very top of the
list of MVP candidates but he's not even
mentioned why do you think that is for
Ben throughout his entire career Hines
Ward you know you kind of I'm kind of
surprised and shocked I mean he's having
a phenomenal year yes pacifically he has
some intercepts is up there but yeah I
just think you know you talk about you
see Aaron Rodgers
playing how the Packers are doing
without them but I just think you take
Ben Roethlisberger and you take them out
of the game the students aren't the same
team and I think for a lot of Antonio
Brown success I think that's a
predicated on Ben Roethlisberger you
know you look at Antonio when he didn't
have been in there you saw his stats and
his catch and dropped automatically so I
just think the two go hand in hand and I
think Ben he deserves recognition for
what he's done
yeah I think he he has the hardware to
support but he never really his name
mentioned an MVP category Hines Ward
here on the Rich Eisen show you you your
name got mentioned quite a bit during
that Cincinnati Bengals game because of
what juju Smith Shuster did to vantes
perfect it's basically called the Hines
Ward rule where that that hit that juju
Smith Shuster delivered became illegal
because you perfected it in such a
manner do you think that should be
illegal hunts the league is trying to
clean the game up but you take every
football player that's been on that
field at one point or another at some
point in time we've all been hit like
that before I mean you see it happening
probably three or four times a game on
the punt return somebody always get
blindsided now I don't agree with juju
standing over top of him he's just young
and that's just the emotions of the game
listen I did that years ago early in my
career but then I kind of like well you
can't do it you can't show more so why
not help
so remember hitting a dream one time and
immediately when I hit him hard I start
calling for the medic to come get him so
I was trying to help attack it as I hit
put a hit on I wasn't really trying to
sell on him or anything but and the
league is cleaning up some of those
heaps of stuff but the way did you hit
him he hit him with a shoulder pad you
know I blame the coaches because you
always got to have your head on the
swivel because that can happen to any
player in any given time while the play
is going on it happens a lot on
publishers if you watch Club return I
can't keep up to one or two guys get
crack back
time but they never called it they never
call it no one ever gets fired and it's
kind of swept under the rug but you know
when they're offensive players does it
to a defensive player you know if it's a
fine
you know it's also in his big news so I
I don't understand them I just walked
efficiency throughout the whole game
what's Tommen like during Patriot Week
Pines what's what do you think in that
locker room opportunity to get a chance
to play the world champions doing the
paper he lives for that you know it's
not like a a cockiness about him but it
was just more a they a confidence he
believes in his team and he really he
challenges his team and he can't wait to
see them not just to see you know let's
go toe to toe with the big dog so that's
just his personality well it's been an
issue trying to beat New England Hines
you know 15 and 1 we beat them in the
regular season they came back and they
whooped our tales in the AFC
Championship game and what Tom Brady did
last year was just unheard of for me yes
I get in he's 40 years old at any time
he's on the field you know I think the
key for the Pittsburgh Steelers they got
to get after him you got to get off and
you can't sit back and play zone because
it just it just pick you apart you know
I think you look at teams who have
success against Brady
it's about getting pressure to get
pressure up the middle and playing
man-to-man I don't know if there's still
a secondary if they have the personnel
to do that but you got you can't sit
back there and do the fire zone the
Blitz and stuff like that Brady's too
smart for that
and I think I'll basically you know you
just got to keep Tom Brady off the field
so for Ben and let me out there and
Tonio Brown just played keep away from
Tom Brady if they can do that they have
a chance to win the game now I know you
can't I'm gonna ask you a question that
that that a player can't control okay so
I can't I can't say they hey you got to
play in the way you play em or whatever
all that business here in that locker
room do you think the Steelers
our are happy that there the Patriots
are coming off of a game that they
looked so horrible in or do you think
that they prefer New England who have
come off of a forty two to three blowout
and let's get them in like that Hines
what do you think yeah I think the
players they they they relish it they
don't want any excuses they they they
want New England's best coming off a
loss against Miami at disappointing it's
rare that you see the Patriots lose two
times in a row well that's why I would
think that you don't want to see them
coming off of the game like that well
listen in order to be the parents you
gotta beat that great so regardless if
the patrons going to give the fill in as
the best as a player as a competitor you
want the best you want to you want to
see where you at this is a barometer for
the Pittsburgh Steelers to see where
where they sit do they really have a
true chance of winning at all so this
could be a great test for the Steelers I
can't wait to watch alright tell me
about on location experiences what
you're doing with the with the league
NFL on location calm what do you got for
me I say long arms is there as long on
the NFL on location comp get the ticket
I went there two years ago in San
Francisco hanging out with market island
we got up on the DJ table leaving three
make sense getting the crowd hype and I
have a great time there was a little too
wholesome offense man if you want to go
there and see some of the great a Hall
of Fame let's see some of the great
players to play the game it's a great
experience for everyone bringing th your
family I guarantee you'll have a good
time so I can't wait to be a part of
this yeah the only source for official
ticket packages with exact seat
locations direct from the National
Football League NFL on location calm all
right Hines don't be a stranger when
you're out here in Los Angeles okay
we'll have you right back at you that's
Hines Ward at MVP 86 Hines Ward on
Twitter right here in the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience